MIT now we can go to MIT is now
publishing a children's book for
communists written by German author BB
Adam Zack who I guess also you said has
some queer politics where politics and
communism now here's something important
we first read about this even one of our
producers said well Sam I think it's MIT
like publishing it doesn't have any to
do with the school yeah it does is MIT
the university is publishing a
children's book on communism extolling
the virtues of communism teaches the
values of communism and presents
communism as quote not that hard here's
something that I find portrays cap evils
of capitalism their little
revolutionaries in this um this is the
perfect target demographic for these
people it's appealing to little greedy
children now I always said well little
capitalism scream no no communism is
greedy let me tell you why because even
if someone looks at the capitalist
system and they're greedy don't matter
well I want that one in one hand and
dump in the other see which one fills up
first that's on my breath the
grandfather used to tell me don't matter
I want and I want it you're cool you're
greedy okay you want it but no one's
giving it to you you have to work for it
now some people cheat for it some people
live for it it's not a perfect system
but you don't simply get it because you
say nee nee nee nee nee nee nee I want I
want I want communism it's I want it
here you go
communism or Marxism or even socialism
is the parent who never spanks their
child is the parent who never gives them
a timeout the kid just said that I
wanted one okay here you go but I was in
college okay here you go but I like
really health care okay here you go
he has more I want I want okay here you
go here you go here you go this is the
ultimate irony is this book that's being
published by MIT by the way if you need
to talk about this is not some small
sector of leftism that's we talk about
critical theory this is important for
people to know it's not just some small
social justice fringe a lot of people
who've been read pilled like to act as
on a classical liberal but this doesn't
know this is the Democratic Party this
is all mainstream universities this is
all mainstream public schools this is
the entire Democratic national platform
and
people who support them now okay you
can't say it's some friends when MIT one
of the most prestigious schools in the
country is printing a communist
manifesto right next to the Hello Kitty
backpacks communism can only function in
a pessimistic greedy society and it's
been it because of professors
generally speaking who are losers who
haven't gone out and accomplished
anything in selected sitting they like
to tell children how they should live
their lives because they're open-minded
um it appeals it's okay you can ensure
that's trying to not stress that's a
laugh it's true that's that's what it is
it's professors who are losers that's
why you why do you have a
disproportionate amount of communists
Marxists and socialists in universities
and why do they all support Bernie
Sanders who was a couchsurfing loser
until he was 43 years old come on
nowhere else in this occurs because a
lot of these professors are losers but
they're intellectuals no they're losers
they're losers who didn't accomplish
enough and so their main their main grab
on a thought on Authority because many
of these professors are authoritarian as
anyone knows who's expressed a different
opinion in the college class campus
reform talks about this a lot is they
have a grip on the students and by god
they're going to make sure that these
students think the same way they think
need more proof look at the studies that
we spoke about just last week in
critical theory look at their how
they're printing communists books for
children it's right out there in the
open let's not allow the myth the
pervasive myth to continue that
capitalism is for greedy pigs no
socialism and communism is for greedy
pigs and it works because what works for
a temporary period of time because what
do you think don't have to do anything
they don't why is it for some reason
selfish for a Ben Carson as we were
talking about raised to a single mother
in Detroit graduating top of his class
was at Naval Academy quitted ROTC I
don't know guy guys an amazing pedigree
why is it selfish for that guy to pull
himself out and to want to enjoy the
fruits of his labor but it's not selfish
for some kid who ran a communist book
from MIT to want to take the fruits of
his labor just shut up about this whole
capitalism is greedy and socialism as
compassionate communism is compassionate
yeah tell that to the hundreds of
millions of people who've been killed
under communist atheist regimes it's the
most evil ideology that's ever existed
it sucks it's never worked oh but mother
you are going to a better shut up and go
to hell I don't care you're completely
off-base it's never going to work
communism sucks the last guy who did it
sucks and you suck so we do actually
have sent out as a promo themselves
teaching this book this communism for
little revolutionaries they're already
there already apparently teaching us at
schools across the country in grade
school they have them young now let's
see okay so this boys and girls is Timmy
doesn't that look nice it was fun Timmy
opened up a lemonade stand and made 85
cents in profit okay we can hate Timmy
ah now why do we hate Timmy does anyone
know why we need to me because Timmy is
a what do we call them what do we call
Timmy's Timmy is a dissident that's
right he's a dissident can anyone say
dissident yes again close Cory and what
do we do with dissidents
does anyone remember we execute them
that's right we execute dissidents yeah
Timmy has to be executed because he's a
greedy capitalist selfish little [ __ ]
Hey video is take another clip from the
full show Daily Show at Lada with Qatar
calm /mo club or it's available
exclusively 69 dollars a year that's
less than $6 a month less than two
expensive cups of coffee or you can feed
an African child but to just buy coffee
or join the Mudd Club Daily Show a lot
of credit calm / mug club see you there
don't feed children